in the battle for ukraine russian forces
are meeting fierce resistance as they
try to advance in the south and east
their objective to capture the
industrial donbass region
a senior u.s defense official says the
russian offensive is moving much slower
than expected the mayor of the bombed
out southern port city of mariupol
describes a situation there as quote
dire with many civilians who sought
refuge in a steel mill barely hanging on
chris livesay has the latest this
morning from key the capital of ukraine
chris good morning
good morning ukraine had announced that
an evacuation was planned to begin
yesterday but there's still no word on
the outcome it all depends on russian
forces cooperating the same russian
forces who have repeatedly broken
ceasefires
relentless bombardment from without and
relentless survival from within
[Music]
after two months of hellish resistance
these border guards seeing the ukrainian
national anthem barricaded inside the
marijuana steel mill that refuses to
topple
up by the love of their wives now
refugees in rome like yulia who has no
hope in russian promises for a safe
evacuation they're very bad people they
light and
no trust to russia
in ukraine's northeast civilians flee
the town of ruskola sova with whatever
and whoever they can carry away from the
advancing russian army
they were small 20 year old boys soviet
helmets and clothes were hanging on them
says irina they had nothing to eat
taking all they could to fill their
pockets
until ukrainian forces came to the
rescue says svetlana i saw them on my
street and i actually from the video
and actually cried
but it was
a grateful cry because i was really glad
to see them now fleeing to the city of
harcave their refuge is itself a
cauldron of war ukraine's second largest
city is just a few miles from the
russian border and russian shelling
cut off from water and electricity many
have no choice but to cook their meals
outside their bombed out homes and as
the front line encroaches harkee becomes
ever more a safe haven in name only
meanwhile the u.s and its allies are
ramping up shipments of heavy artillery
that will be crucial to ukraine in this
next decisive phase in the east in a war
that could last for months or years for
cbs saturday morning chris livesay keiv